you know that New York city mayor Eric
Adams who's a liberal Democrat he just
came out he said this immigration crisis
this is going to destroy New York City
and this is after Eric Adams had said
for a long time we're Sanctuary City
diversity is our strength everyone's
welcome here but then they started
coming after Greg Abbott and Ron
DeSantis sent buses up to New York and
all of a sudden Eric Adams changed his
tune well now that Eric Adams changed
his tune even the Liberals on The View
who are as establishment lib as they get
even they after years of diversity is
our strength and no one is illegal and
Sanctuary cities are great
they're changing they're tuned too
this issue
will destroy New York City the city we
knew
we're about to lose
but frankly you know I think we need to
find and we've dealt with this before I
I lived in uh in Miami I was a migrant
an immigrant in Miami in the 80s you'll
remember when we had the Marielle Boat
Lift yeah 125 000 Cubans came in a
matter of six months it puts tremendous
stress on on on a city on a community on
the social services they need to be
resettled elsewhere right they need to
be out with a massive country and it's
only going to get worse with global
warming and climate change because
people can't live in certain parts of
this world and don't forget about this
totally unrelated Boogeyman we got to
get that in here to every story
but but listen to what NFL is a huge
live but just look but they got it we
got to spread these immigrants out we
can't come on these immigrants they're
going to destroy New York City well hold
on I thought the immigrants were our
strength
I thought We're a nation of immigrants
New York's a City Event where the more
immigrants the better
but then Eric Adams mayor of New York
changed his tune and now all the other
Liberals are changing their tune too why
because
Anna Navarro knows that she's on the
same team as Eric Adams
and
Eric Adams flipped
and so now the rest of the team is going
to flip
this is a concept in political theory
that uh the
political boils down to a distinction
between friends and enemies
it's this is something that isn't often
spoken about explicitly because it was
articulated most clearly by a political
philosopher named Carl Schmidt and Carl
Schmidt had The Misfortune of Being a
German in the 1930s like Heidegger and
so he's you know kind of been canceled
but even Leo Strauss for instance
another great political philosopher
largely exonerates Carl Schmidt of a lot
of the nasty charges against him and so
I think it's I think it's fair to
mention this point because the point
he's making here is obviously true that
the political boils down to very
practical things it's not just Pie in
the Sky guys it's not just abstractions
it boils down to are you on my team are
you on are you on the other team if
you're on my team I'm going to show you
more grace if you're on the other team
we're going to try to drive you out of
the Public Square
and I there are a lot of squishy lib
types who bemoan the fact that politics
has become so tribal these days politics
has always been tribal partisan politics
has always been partisan that's that's
what a party is
and
the the this notion that there's a
distinction between friends and enemies
it actually goes much much deeper than
some political differences you know
Democrats and Republicans left and right
it's a it's a basic question you know
Ronald Reagan used to say that we have
we have no enemies only opponents here
and so we'd always talk about his
Democrat opponents and there's something
really beautifully true about that
because if you call your domestic
adversaries your enemies what you're
doing is saying that there is no there's
no cohesive political unit here with the
right to declare war with the right to
declare who really is an enemy with the
right to really move the entire body
politic and so I I think it's really
beautiful that Ronald Reagan tried to
avoid that increasingly though you hear
the left talk about us as enemies and
you're the right talk about the leftist
enemies that tells you about a breakdown
in the political order right now go to
proviahair.com are you one of the
millions of American men and women
dealing with premature hair thinning and
hair loss well
maybe you're scared about inheriting
that thinning look because it runs in
the family finally there is a real
solution that delivers on its promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals and unpleasant smells Previa
Hair Care uses a safe natural ingredient
called procapil to effectively Target
the three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss previous Awards
healthy scalp circulation and delivers
nourishing nutrients to strengthen hair
follicles and anchor them to your scalp
pravia guarantees more hair on your head
than in the shower drain Previa is
effective for men and women of any age
and safe uncolored treated and styled
hair Previa Works guaranteed or 100 of
your money back it is that easy you know
I have relied on my hair a lot in my
public life right now new customers save
over 50 off previous introductory
package at previahair.com null see
results for yourself right now do not
wait proviahair.com Knowles
president Trump the chief rival to Joe
Biden right now has just received a
really really big
endorsement this from South Dakota
governor Christino
[Applause]
to present to you the man in the arena
he is a man of significance he is the
leader the fighter that our country
needs he has my full and complete
endorsement for president of the United
States of America
I will do everything I can to help him
win and save this country ladies and
gentlemen the 45th and the 47th
president of the United States Donald J
Trump there you have it I generally have
not covered endorsements
I mentioned early on when DeSantis was
getting some some congressmen because
they were some of the first endorsements
that he had gotten people who decided to
turn on Trump and go for another guy I
haven't really covered many of the
endorsements since then the reason I'm
covering this one the reason that this
one is significant is because
Christy gnome is not just a republican
governor
she was a potential presidential
candidate Christy gnome like Glenn
Younkin in Virginia was obviously
considering running for president
herself she set herself up to do that
during kovid she was playing kind of koi
with it after kovid right up until a
couple days ago I guess now she's
decided that she's going to endorse
Trump which to me says not only that she
thinks that Trump is the best candidate
which is explicitly what she's saying
but what it what it means is
she believes that Trump just is going to
be the nominee
and so she thinks not only is it her
interest to get on Trump's side in this
battle between him and DeSantis and
Vivek and Chris Christie or whoever but
she thinks it's in her interest not to
run against him trust me if Christie
gnome thought that Donald Trump had any
weakness right now and that she would
have a shot at the presidency she would
be running inside every Governor is a
president just waiting to get out some
uncharitable people have asked how many
Governors how many presidents are
waiting inside of Chris Christie which I
don't that's not very nice that's not
that's an honest thing to say at all but
Christy gnome wants to be president and
she's not going to run and she is going
to endorse this guy because she thinks
in another sign of something we've been
talking about for weeks that the
presidential primary is if not over
pretty severely tilted in the direction
of Donald John Trump boy what a great
clip that was now make sure that you
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel see you next
time